en un salón como ese
con más de 150 niños,
durante más de 6 años.
En ese tiempo, un día fui a la escuela
y me di cuenta de que mi compañero de clases había muerto.
Hoy en día no ha cambiado mucho.
Aún no hay electricidad en mi pueblo.
La gente sigue muriendo en Burkina Faso,
y el acceso a agua potable limpia
es aún un gran problema.
Tuve suerte. Tuve suerte, porque esto es una realidad
cuando creces en un lugar como ese.
Pero tuve suerte.
Obtuve una beca.
Pude ir a Alemania a estudiar.
Así que supongo que ahora
no necesito explicarles qué tan grande es el privilegio
de estar hoy frente a Uds.
Desde Gando, mi pueblo natal en Burkina Faso,
a Berlín en Alemania para ser arquitecto
es un gran paso, un gran, gran paso.
Pero, ¿qué hago con este privilegio?
Desde que era estudiante quería brindar
mejores oportunidades a otros niños en Gando.
Solo quería usar mis habilidades y construir una escuela.
Pero, ¿cómo hacerlo cuando aún eres solo un estudiante
y no tienes dinero?
Por supuesto, empecé a hacer diseños
y a recolectar dinero
Recaudar fondos no fue un trabajo fácil.
Hasta les pedía a mis compañeros
que gastaran menos dinero en café y cigarrillos,
y patrocinaran mi proyecto escolar.
Asombrosamente, 2 años después,
pude recolectar USD 50 000.
Cuando regresé a mi hogar en Gando
para dar las buenas nuevas,
mi gente saltaba de alegría,
pero cuando se dieron cuenta
de que estaba planeando usar arcilla
se quedaron paralizados.
"Un edificación de arcilla no puede sostenerse en invierno,
y Francis quiere que lo usemos para construir una escuela.
¿Para eso pasó tanto tiempo
estudiando en Europa
en vez de ayudarnos a labrar la tierra?"
Mi gente construía todo el tiempo con arcilla,
y ellos no veían innovación alguna en la tierra.
Así que tuve que convencer a todo el mundo.
Empecé a hablar con la comunidad,
y pude convencerlos,
y pudimos empezar a trabajar.
Mujeres, hombres,
y todos en el pueblo,
eran parte del proceso de construcción.
Podía incluso usar técnicas tradicionales.
Como el piso de arcilla, por ejemplo,
los jóvenes llegaban y se paraban así, golpeando,
hora tras hora,
y luego llegaban sus madres,
y golpeaban de esta manera
durante horas; poniendo agua y golpeando.
Y luego llegaban los pulidores.
Empezaban a pulir con piedras durante horas.
Y luego se obtenía este resultado,
bien pulido, como las nalgas de un bebé.
(Risas)
No es PhotoShop. (Risas)
Esta es la escuela, construida con la comunidad.
Las paredes fueron completamente construidas
en bloques de arcilla comprimida de Gando.
La estructura del techo se hizo
con barras baratas de hierro
normalmente forradas en concreto.
Y en el salón de clases, el techo se hizo
con ambos materiales.
En esta escuela, había una idea simple:
crear un salón de clases cómodo.
No olviden que en Burkina Faso puede hacer 45 °C,
así que con simple ventilación,
quería construir el salón apropiado
para la enseñanza y el aprendizaje.
Y este es el proyecto hoy en día,
12 años después, aún en las mejores condiciones.
Y los niños lo aman.
Y para mí y mi comunidad,
este proyecto fue un gran éxito.
Nos abrió oportunidades
de poder llevar a cabo más proyectos en Gando.
Así que pude realizar muchísimos proyectos.
Y aquí compartiré con Uds.
solo 3 de ellos.
El primero es la ampliación de la escuela, por supuesto.
¿Cómo explicarle diseño e ingeniería
a personas que no saben leer ni escribir?
Empecé a crear un prototipo como ese.
La innovación era construir una cúpula de barro.
Así que salté a la cima así
con mi equipo y funcionó.
La comunidad estaba a la expectativa. Aún funciona.
Así que a construir. (Risas)
Y continuamos construyendo, y ese es el resultado.
Los niños estaban muy contentos, y les encantó.
La comunidad estaba muy orgullosa. La construimos.
Y hasta los animales, como ese burro,
amaban nuestro edificio.
(Risas)
El siguiente proyecto es la biblioteca en Gando.
Y vean ahora que tratamos de usar
ideas diferentes en nuestros edificios,
aunque generalmente no tenemos muchos materiales.
Algo que tenemos en Gando son vasijas de arcilla.
Queríamos usarlas para crear aperturas.
Así que las pusimos como pueden ver
en el sitio de la construcción.
Empezamos a cortarlas,
y luego las colocamos en el tope del techo
antes de vaciar el cemento,
y obtuvimos este resultado.
Las aperturas dejan salir el aire caliente
y hacen que entre la luz.
Muy simple.
Mi proyecto más reciente en Gando
es una escuela secundaria.
Me gustaría compartir esto con Uds.
La innovación en este proyecto
es vaciar el lodo como se vacía el cemento.
¿Cómo se vacía el lodo?
Empezamos a crear muchos morteros, como pueden ver,
y cuando todo estaba listo,
cuando sabíamos cuál era la mejor receta,
la mejor manera,
empezamos a trabajar con la comunidad.
Y algunas veces me puedo ir.
Ellos lo harán por sí mismos.
Gracias a eso, hoy pude venir a hablarles a Uds.
Otro factor en Gando es la lluvia.
Cuando llegó la lluvia
nos apresuramos a proteger nuestras frágiles paredes
de la lluvia.
No se confundan con Christo y Jeanne-Claude.
Es simplemente como protegíamos nuestras paredes.
(Risas)
La lluvia en Burkina llega muy rápidamente,
y con ella llegan las inundaciones
en todo el país.
Pero para nosotros, la lluvia era buena.
Trae consigo arena y grava a los ríos
que necesitábamos para construir.
Solo esperábamos que escampara.
Tomábamos la arena, la mezclábamos con la arcilla,
y continuábamos trabajando.
Y así era.
El proyecto de Gando siempre estuvo conectado al entrenamiento de la gente,
porque deseo que el día
que me desgaste y muera,
al menos una persona de Gando
continúe haciendo este trabajo.
Pero se sorprenderán al ver que sigo vivo.
(Risas)
Y mi pueblo ahora puede usar sus habilidades
para ganar dinero por sí mismo.
Por lo general, para que un joven de Gando gane dinero,
tiene que dejar el campo
e irse a la ciudad; algunas veces se van
y no regresan,
lo que debilita a la comunidad.
Pero ahora pueden quedarse en el campo
y trabajar en diferentes sitios de construcción
y ganar dinero para alimentar a sus familias.
Pero este trabajo tiene algo más.
Sí, ya lo saben.
He ganado cientos de premios gracias a este trabajo.
Ciertamente, me ha dado oportunidades.
Me ha ayudado a ser reconocido.
Pero la razón para hacer lo que hago
es mi comunidad.
Cuando era niño,
iba a la escuela
y regresaba a Gando en las vacaciones.
Al final de las vacaciones
debía despedirme de la comunidad,
yendo de un recinto a otro.
Todas las mujeres en Gando sacaban su ropa de esta manera
y me daban la última moneda.
En mi cultura, este es un símbolo de profundo afecto.
Con tan solo 7 años, estaba impresionado.
Un día le pregunté a mi madre:
"¿Por qué todas estas mujeres me aman tanto?"
(Risas)
Ella solo respondió:
"Están contribuyendo a pagar tu educación
con la esperanza de que tengas éxito
y un día regreses y ayudes
a mejorar la calidad de vida de la comunidad".
Ahora espero que mi comunidad esté orgullosa
gracias a este trabajo.
Espero poder demostrarles el poder
de la comunidad,
y mostrarles que la arquitectura
puede ser inspiradora para las comunidades
para forjarse su propio futuro.
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)
Muchas gracias. Muchas, muchas gracias.
Gracias. Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)